I believe there is a stranger comes to
this village from the sea it comes in
the winter when the people are hungry it
brings fish he comes on the king tide I
was last night they want to add felt
teeth those goodies killers who tell us
icebergs in the harbor for months and so
a ship got through
well this stranger doesn't come by ship
there are enemies coming from far away I
need warriors I'm building an alliance
and defend ourselves you should get out
can't you at least point me to Atlantis
Barth or curry
also known as protector of the oceans
the Aquaman here you can talk to fish I
know you have abilities I just don't
know what they are my special skills
include viola a web design fluent in
sign language gorilla sign language
silica based quartz and fabric
Rajon resistant heat resistant yeah I do
competitive ice dancing what they use on
the space shuttle to prevent it from
burning up on re-entry I do very
competitive ice dancing whoever you're
looking for
[Music]
[Music]
use a Batman
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team people with special abilities you
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there
I'm in you are yeah I need friends
[Music]
what did you do this weekend Diana me
huh nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman he said the age of heroes
who never come again but asked him
[Music]
we don't have anymore time
[Music]
something is calling
no education
no language
[Music]
love you Tony
[Music]
which made this yeah
like all the others one this is the days
where mums biggest concerns were
exploding wind-up penguins this is crazy
our surfing rogue and die
each of us in some way is held back
don't engage alone until this together
it's really cool you guys seem ready to
do battle and stuff I've never done
battle
relax Alfred don't take it from here do
I know you
Superman was a beacon to the world
to save people and they could see the
best parts of themselves
I don't recognize as well
we all have to recognize
[Music]
which is that Pacific
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough do
you really think this oh wow they just
they really just vanish huh oh that's
rude
you said you've come
now that's hope you're not too late
[Music]